[موسيقى]
نحن متواجدون هناك نتعاون ايضا مع الصليب
الاحمر الاوكراني وهناك امر مهم للغايه
حتى يتم التخفيف من المعاناه وهو احترام
القانون الانساني الدولي
الاتفاقيات التي تحمي العمل الانسان يجب
ان تسري وينبغي احترام هذه الاتفاقيات
وتطبيقها
[موسيقى]
وهذا هو السبب الذي يجعلنا تعاون مع
السلطات في اوكرانيا وكذلك في روسيا بشان
ضروره
التقيد
بالقانون الانساني الدولي لحمايه المدنيين
وكذلك البنيه التحتيه المدنيه علاوه على
حمايه
السجناء الحرب او المعتقلين من المدنيين
[موسيقى]
كانت لدينا اولويه خلال فصل الشتاء الراهن
الا وهي ضمان ان اكثر الناس ضعفا يكون
لديهم ماوى وسبل الحصول على التدفئه في
شهرين يناير وفبراير ولكن لدينا اولويات
اخرى الا وهي تقديم الدعم
فيتعلق
بالمساعده البلديات لتقديم المياه الصالحه
للشرب والكهرباء
للمستشفيات حتى تواصل هذه الانظمه عملها
هذه اولويه عملنا عليها بالتعاون مع
البلديات والسلطات المسؤول
[موسيقى]